[Music]
what really happens when we cut a cake
using a knife in physics we could say
that the cake experiences stress usually
when we cut a cake we hold the knife
straight and apply the force
perpendicular to the surface area so can
you guess what type of stress this is it
is normal stress as the force is acting
perpendicular to this area but what
about these cross-sectional areas of the
cake the area on top is not the only
area that experiences stress as we
pierce the knife in this cross-sectional
area experiences stress - it doesn't
look too obvious but it does experience
stress we can also see that the force is
not perpendicular to this area
it acts parallel to it as we're pushing
the knife straight down if the force
acts parallel to the surface it exerts
shear stress this stress tries to push
the two surfaces away from each other
and hence results in plastic deformation
so this is the basic difference between
normal stress and shear stress normal
stress is where the force is acting
perpendicular to the area of contact
while shear stress is the force that
acts parallel to the area let's take
another example which explains shear
stress better here's a beam and assume
that it's fixed at its base if we apply
normal force to this cross-sectional
area then we know that the stress
experienced by the beam will be normal
stress which is simply given by F over a
where F is the applied force and a is
this cross-sectional area this will
result in a normal strain in the beam
which is given by Delta L over L where
Delta L is the change in length and L is
the original length now suppose that we
apply a force in this direction parallel
to area a again the beam will experience
some stress but this time it will be a
shear stress
the equation or formula for shear stress
is the same as that of normal stress
stress is simply the applied force per
unit area whether it's acting
perpendicular or parallel to the area
what about the deformation in the beam
by shear force here the deformation will
be something like this the object is
stretched to some extent
note that the beam is fixed to the base
so this cross-sectional surface will
remain where it is whereas the
cross-sections above it will all get
displaced to the right by increasing
amounts now look at the maximum
displacement here let's call it Delta X
we know that this length is L it's
perpendicular to this also notice that
there's an angle formed here we can call
it theta with this information in place
let us define what shear strain is shear
strain is simply equal to tangent of
theta yes
shear strain is simply the tangent of
this angle but what is tan theta we know
that it's the opposite side over the
adjacent side here the length of the
opposite side of theta is Delta X and
length of adjacent side is L so it's
equal to Delta x over L so that's how
shear strain is defined lengths of the
deformation at its maximum over this
perpendicular length
[Music]
you